bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission économique qui va vous rappeler
quelques principes de base mathématique
ainsi qu'à nos chers ministres du
gouvernement
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de bruno le maire
presqu'exclusivement bonjour estelle
bonjour olivier bonjour à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de c'est caché
qu'elle croissance pour 2021 les 6% de
croissance du pib en temps envisagée par
le gouvernement sont il réalisable
comment sortir de cette économie sous
perfusion on va en parler
dans cette émission et en deuxième
partie nous serons en liaison avec
philippe chalmin historien économiste et
fondateur du cercle cyclope de 8% en
septembre 2020 à 6 à la mi novembre
les prévisions de croissance pour
l'année 2000 21 n'auront jamais été
aussi incertaine alors que bercy sont
semblait plutôt tabler sur une
croissance du pib à 6 % pour cette année
bruno le maire a temporisé et évoquent
désormais un défi
explications avec le tiroir cash
d'antoine basses bruno le maire s'est il
un peu avancé en annonçant le rebond
économique tant attendue pour 2021 et un
objectif de 6% de croissance c'est à
peine plus que les prévisions de l'insee
ou de la banque de france qui table tous
les deux sur 5 % pour 2021
mon pour calmer les esprits sachez que
les chiffres pour 2020 pas encore
définitif table sur une récession entre
9 et 11% et au donc même si les
objectifs de 2021 sont atteints les
niveaux d'avant crise ne seront pas
retrouvés cette année
mais revenons à notre annonce de
croissance de bruno le maire
écran traîné
objectif atteignable en fait il n'y a
pas de secret tous les experts le disent
tout va dépendre de la pandémie et du
vaccin
si les mesures sanitaires peuvent être
mauvais si tous les commerces sont
rouverts si la consommation repart et si
le réel impact du virus ne se fait pas
sentir sur le tard ou plus dur est de
vendre
on l'a entendu et réentendu de la part
du gouvernement ou même ici dans ces
caches car si toute l'économie est
encore pour le moment perfusé à coups de
milliards et aides en tous genres que se
passera-t-il lorsque les dispositifs
d'urgence seront levés les entreprises
tiendront-elles le coup et arriveront
elles à rembourser les femmes ont péché
aux prêts garantis par l'état etc sont
tout de même 683 milliards en avoir
contracté l'assureur euren hermès à
d'ores et déjà avancé des chiffres qui
pourraient casser l'optimisme de bruno
le maire les faillites d'entreprises
pourrait s'élever à 50 milles en 2021 et
plus de 60000 en 2022
[Musique]
la croissance c'est quoi la croissance
c'est c'est aussi une croissance je
dirais une croissance potentielle et la
croissance potentielle en france on sait
très bien que ça fait très longtemps
qu'elle a quitté la zone des 6 % si vous
les 6 % c'était dans les années 60 e
là on n'y est plus depuis un bon moment
donc le potentiel de croissance en
france c'est entre 0 et 1
alors qui a un effet de rattrapage
évidemment que vous avez un effet de
rattrapage quand vous rouvray certains
commerces et certaines entreprises
évidemment ça fait un petit peu de
business mais il faut pour ça qu'elle
puisse rouvrir
et là c'est pas le cas vous savez que on
est tous sens dans la tente du d'un
nouveau confinement qu'on va
probablement avoir qui va être paraît-il
dur donc plutôt cheap mars que type
novembre et donc que je vois pas très
bien comment on pourrait avoir une
reprise économique
alors monsieur le maire table aussi sur
les pas ramené ménages qui va je pense
qu'il va trouver un moyen de nous piquer
notre épargne et parle parce qu'il a
toujours pas compris que cette épargne
c'était c'était parce que les gens ont
peur les gens ont peur de 2,2 ce qui va
se passer les gens ont peur de la de la
reprise et de ce qui aura de faillite et
de mise au chômage et de licenciement
donc voilà le le problème il est là
c'est à dire que bien sûr que vous
pouvez avoir 6% à ce moment là mettez
mettez sur la table comme le font les
états unis 2000 milliards et puis vous
aurez de la croissance simplement il
faudra les rembourser un jour ces deux
mille milliards
et c'est là que le bât blesse donc on
peut simuler une croissance mais une
vraie croissance qui repose sur des
fondamentaux solides
vous n'êtes pas prêt de la voir et c'est
pour ça que 2022 pensé qu'on allait
revenir sur le la croissance d'avant
c'est idiot encore une fois merci
olivier on passe tout de suite à la
deuxième partie de cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec philippe chalmin bonjour vous êtes
historien économiste et fondateur du
cercle cyclope bienvenue dans ces caches
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
bonjour pour commencer à monsieur
chalmin peut-être une réaction à ce que
olivier adier dans la première partie
d'un groupe et je le trouve gentiment à
juste vis-à-vis de bruno le maire
c'est comme si vous accusez à un pompier
alors qu'il ya encore le feu est alors
qu'il ya encore des départs de feu un
peu partout
objectivement personne ne sait ce que
sera la croissance de la france mais
aussi de la plupart des pays européens
en 2021
la prévision de bruno le maire il ya
quelques semaines avant que l'on parle
de 3e confinant à 6 % pouvaient être
réaliste les familles a sorti une
prévision à 5 5%
et vous savez la science économique ce
n'est pas une science exacte donc on
était dans le même scénario de
rattrapage si effectivement il ya un
troisième confinement bas ce sera
forcément moins et il ne faut pas s'en
faire d'illusions maintenant je n'achète
absolument pas la prévision gentiment
catastrophiste de zéro voire de négatifs
sauf si la pandémie rebondissait
totalement mes prévisions à moi mais je
n'ai guère d'importance en la matière en
imaginant un scénario relativement soft
de la pandémie dont on serait débarrassé
à la fin du premier semestre avec une
vaccination relativement efficace ce
serait d'avoir une croissance française
de l'ordre de 4 à 5 % ce qui de toute
manière ne correspondra pas aux animaux
aura ce ne sera pas le rattrapage
suffisant par rapport à la chute de 2020
et ça ne serait qu'en 2022 voire même
peut-être en 2023 que nous retrouverions
les niveaux de 2019 et là où je ne suis
absolument pas d'accord c'est le
ce que notre ami parler du potentiel de
croissance de la france je le dirai que
le potentiel de croissance tel que le
calcule les économistes se situe plus
aux alentours de 1 5 à 2%
faut pas se faire d'illusions le temps
on avait des croissances de 3 4%
ça je suis bien d'accord il est
totalement révolu la croissance soit et
c'est pas compliqué c'est à un tiroir
consommation un tiroir investissements
des entreprises
un tiroir commerce extérieur côté
commerce extérieur on n'est pas très
brillant
et là le direct l'élément qui a toujours
tiré ces dernières années la croissance
française c'est la consommation
l'investissement des entreprises étant
quand même un petit peu en deçà mais
objectivement la situation française
elle n'est pas pire que celle que nous
connaissons chez des voisins du club med
et italie espagne ou même chez nos
voisins allemands
une réaction à ce que vous bien me dire
monsieur seulement quand ma fille
revenait de
ça son école et qu'elle me disait j'ai
une mauvaise note mais c'est pas grave
parce que tout le monde a une mauvaise
note
je lui disais que c'était pas le sujet
c'est pas parce que nos voisins
européens
les italiens les espagnols et serra ont
des mauvaises notes qu'il faut en avoir
une sur le potentiel de croissance je
vous rappelle simplement que la france
vieillit c'est une question
démographique pour moi qu'ils inventent
et
et on est loin du taux de remplacement à
2,10 on est aujourd'hui à 1,86 et je
pense que le le la crise va donner un
coup d'arrêt à tout ça et que l'on
risque de retomber sur le taux de
natalité de nos voisins qui est plutôt
autour de 1,30 en ce moment ce qui est
pas brillant d'accord donc vous avez ce
phénomène là et il se trouve que je ne
vous la prendrai pas en tant
qu'économiste que un vieux ça consomme
moins qu'un jeune ça c'est un truc qu'on
connaît tous dans les études
démographiques quelqu'un qui a plus de
75 ans par exemple ça consomme beaucoup
moins que 1
un jeune entre 20 25 20 et 59 ans donc
ça pèse sur la croissance attendue et
malheureusement ça pèse sur ce que vous
pouvez avoir comme potentiel de
croissance et non nous ne sommes pas
entrain et demi et deux nous serions
plutôt en dessous de 1% et et c'est un
fait bon alors après on peut toujours
souhaiter qu'un jour la croissance
reviendra on peut souhaiter aussi que
toute l'épargné accumulée pendant 2020
et 2021 se déverse dans la consommation
et que nous faisions un peu de
croissance avec ça mais malheureusement
j'ai peur que ça ne se passe pas
exactement comme ça maintenant vous me
dit que je suis injuste avec bruno le
maire je vous rappelle que ça n'est pas
le virus qui tue l'économie ce sont les
mesures qu'on a appliqué pour bloquer
l'économie c'est à dire fermez les
restaurants fermés les bars fermés aussi
tout le reste de l'événementiel et
caetera et aujourd'hui nous mettre à la
niche
depuis des mois et des mois c'est à dire
enfermés chez nous ce qui n'est jamais
arrivé dans l'histoire
vous qui êtes historien vous vous m'en
tiendrais leu leu leu la corde ça c'est
que ça ne s'est jamais produit dans
l'histoire et aujourd'hui si vous voulez
les mesures comprend sont un bon alibi
le coc vide est un bon ami pour toutes
les bêtises qu'on a fait avant
économique depuis 13 ans et donc
monsieur bruno le maire en fait partie
et donc je dis il ne calcule pas bien on
le sait depuis un bon moment puisqu'ils
n'étaient même pas fichu de savoir ce
qu'était un hectare et que 100 mètres
sur 100 m ça faisait dix mille mètres
carrés donc y'a du y a du boulot à faire
avec monsieur le maire pour leur mettre
au niveau et je n'avais pas si
pensez vous pouvez pas faire 6% pardon
je voudrais également mais répondait
monsieur bédié et moi me forme que vous
mélangez un peu n'importe quoi et je
trouve que c'est pas la place de faire
le procès personnel de bruno le maire
qui je vous le signale fut en son temps
peut-être ne savait qu il pas ce qu est
un hectare et nombre de nos
téléspectateurs ne le savent pas non
plus il fut en son temps un excellent
ministre de l'agriculture
alors arrêtez de tout mélanger il n'ya
pas nous sommes dans une situation dans
lequel effectivement la question
économique est sujette de problèmes
sanitaires et politiques qui nous
dépasse j'ai mes opinions
en tant que citoyen sur le confinement
et les mesures qui sont prises
je peux les critiques et en tant que
citoyen maintenant en tant qu'économiste
je suis obligé de prendre en compte ce
qui a été fait en france ce qui est fait
d'ailleurs dans bien d'autres pays
il n'ya pas malheureusement cher
monsieur de martingale idéal
enfin sur votre premier point permettez
moi de vous dire que vous sortiez une
ineptie
dans la mesure où s'il est un point sur
lequel la france a été relativement
exemplaire et même curieusement
exemplaires c'était la démographie nous
avons eu pendant alors ça va peut-être
baissé en 2020 du fait du coc vide mais
nous avons un taux de natalité est
surtout un taux de fécondité qui est
probablement un des plus élevé de
l'ensemble de l'europe et donc votre
remarque
oui nous sommes des populations
vieillissantes pourquoi vieillissons
nous non pas parce que nous faisons
moins d'enfants et nous en faisons
beaucoup en france mais surtout parce
que nous avons une espérance de vie
beaucoup plus longue
et c'est cela qui explique et détrompez
vous les vieux entre guillemets rats les
personnes âgées et temps dans la zone
des soixante dix ans je paume mettre
là-dedans autre pouvoir d'achat bien
supérieure et une propension à consommer
qui n'est pas négligeable du tout et ça
fait partie aussi au travers des
transferts intergénérationnels
d'une forme de croissance arrêtez de
tout mélanger
nous sommes dans ce monsieur je ne
mélange rien elle s'est affirmée mais
les choses sont en hausse
c'est facile il demande des chiffres
monsieur quand vous dites il ya bon taux
de fécondité en france c'est lille était
de 2 10 je vous dis donc au dessus du
taux de remplacement
on y est plus on est à un canoë
messieurs dames n'est de loin pas on est
on est on est un bon taux de mapei
l'océan
donc il ne faut pas dire des bêtises non
plus mes nouvelles et hamish monsieur
depuis deux ans
l'émission va voir si on va continuer le
débat on va on va poursuivre sur la
croissance 2021 mais avant cela on a
marqué une courte pause bienvenue dans
ces caches si vous rejoignez quelle
croissance pour 2021 c'est la question à
qu'on se pose aujourd'hui dans cette
émission et pour cela nous sommes en
liaison avec philippe chalmin historien
économiste et fondateur du cercle est
cyclable à monsieur celle main à
l'économie on le sait est sous perfusion
pour le moment quel scénario peut-on
envisager lorsqu'il va s'agir pour le
gouvernement de débrancher les
dispositifs de soutien est ce que cet
éventuel rebond économique dépend aussi
de la façon dont l'état va
dont l'état va faire pense que l'état va
faire pour justement débrancher sept
dispositifs de soutien là vous avez
totalement raison
on aura on a effectivement aujourd'hui
une économie assez largement sous
perfusion et on sait très bien que quand
il y aura probablement une reprise avec
la vie normale dans un certain nombre de
secteurs
il y à un certain nombre de cas dont les
entreprises ne se relèveront pas
l'augmentation des défaillances alors de
manière assez curieuse on a eu en 2020
une diminution du nombre des
défaillances
il faut s'attendre à ce qu'ils ne me
demanderont des défaillances dans
d'entreprise et il faut s'attendre quand
même bon quel que soit le moment du
rebond
finalement nous ne savons pas
aujourd'hui dire à quel moment va
intervenir le le pic du coc vide
une fois le pic de kobe de passer une
fois qu'on sera dans la période vraiment
de l'atterrissage en douceur à ce moment
là il y aura un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui commenceront à tomber
c'est là que l'on pourra faire l'état
des dégâts mais ce taux de très fortes
probabilités et d'ailleurs vous n'avez
qu'à reprendre supa vérité d'évangile
mais enfin les prévisions du fmi qui
sont tout le mérite d'être relativement
neutre parce que distante et regardant
la france de l'extérieur elle donne à
situation sanitaire à peu près normale
donc c'est un énorme pas rapplique on
ouvre là elle donne 5 5% de croissance
pour la france en 2021 est déjà plus que
4 1% en 2022
et puis probablement encore un peu moins
il faut prendre conscience du fait que
la france
le monde connaît aujourd'hui
la crise la plus forte qu'il ait jamais
connue depuis la grande dépression le le
poids le plus bas de la crise qui
intervient grossièrement au deuxième
trimestre 2020 il n'est comparable qu
est ce que c était passé au deuxième
trimestre 2000
de 1931 donc rendez vous compte de ce
que salah a pu représenter comme choc
comme choc pour l'ensemble des pays
c'est vrai qu'il y en a qui se sont
dopés beaucoup plus avec des plans de
relance beaucoup beaucoup plus important
je pense aux états unis je pense même
d'ailleurs à peu à l'allemagne de ce
point de vue là à la limite
la france a été un des pays peut-être
parmi les plus raisonnables mais on a
passé cette crise
et c'est quand même aussi il faut le
remarquer avec un fonctionnement de
reverte la part des dépenses publiques
dans le pipe
elle est montée à 65% ou à peu près
parce que c'était l'urgence il va
falloir qu'elle redescende
et malheureusement toutes les réformes
qui avait été envisagée par le
gouvernement
à tort ou à raison se sont totalement
arrêtées et je dirais que le président
suivant après 2022 va repartir
pratiquement avec une page blanche
voyage est une réaction à ces propos de
cet économiste de l'institut thomas ce
mot l'état doit cibler ses interventions
sur celles qui peuvent rapidement élevé
le pib et créer des emplois il peut le
faire en accord avec la banque centrale
européenne
la seconde priorité devait être de
restructurer les bilans des sociétés
affaibli par le cos vide c'est ce qu'il
a donc déclaré dans le figaro début
janvier cibler les entreprises et les
entreprises viables et laisser mourir
les autres une solution on en avait déjà
parlé ici il ya quelques il ya quelque
temps à propos justement de de ces aides
qui n'étaient pas des aides ciblées qui
était qui donc
étaient aussi distribué à des
entreprises sont bi des entreprises qui
n'avaient avait un modèle économique qui
les a menés à la liquidation gentiment
depuis déjà un bon moment et qu'ils ont
avec ce prétexte qu vite si vous voulez
ont pu tenir quelques temps en plus
parce que ayant eu des subventions est
donc aujourd'hui il est évident que cet
argent qui est distribué à des sociétés
qui de toute façon feront faillite dans
quelques mois ou dans quelques semaines
n'est pas la manière la plus
intelligente de débourser de l'argent
mais c'est également un vent de ce
qu'était un mois sur l épargne des
ménages selon la banque de france ils
ont accumulé 130 milliards d'euros
d'épargné en 2020 à cela ils devraient
s'ajouter 70 milliards supplémentaires
en 2021
une réserve de croissance significatif
selon l'institution le comportement des
ménages il va jouer sur l'éventuelle
croissant de 2021
oui parce que traditionnellement c'est
que c'est quand même la consommation des
ménages qui en france a toujours été
quand même un des moteurs majeurs de
l'économie en 2020 pour des tas de
raisons
la consommation a été moindre
elle a été réorientée d'ailleurs de
certains secteurs vers d'autres on peut
espérer qu'avec un retour à la normale
nous aurons un sursaut de consommation
n'oublions pas quand même que une des
raisons pour laquelle la france mais
aussi des pays comme l'espagne et
l'italie ont plus souffert
qu'un pays comme l'allemagne c'est que
nous avons une part plus importante en
ce qui concerne les services et en
particulier en ce qui concerne le
tourisme
regardez simplement ce que va
représenter pour l'industrie des sports
d'hiver
le coût d'une saison blanche comme celle
que nous connaissons
je ne juge pas de savoir s'il fallait ou
non fermer
remontées mécaniques ça c'est une
décision politique l'économiste derrière
il ne peut que constater et il est
évident que bach l'argent que les gens
ne vont pas dépenser cette année en se
payant une semaine au ski
ils ne vont pas les grands c'est du tout
donc ça va être donné par une élite à
leurs lames autrement olivier vous alors
le risque de chômage lapin aussi du côté
des gens est ce que c'est pas un peu
utopique de penser que cet état ne va
être tout simplement réinjectés dans
l'économie du jour au lendemain elle ne
sera le chômage a augmenté
moshi suivent coyne frappé alors je suis
peut être mal placé
professeur en université autant mes
étudiants souffre actuellement du fait
d'être en confinement d'être tout seul
et c'est autant ceux de la promotion qui
sorti l'année dernière
je suis frappé de voir que ben ils se
sont à peu près correctement tous
intégrés soit on poursuite de ce stage
soit des gens cdi ou autre donc je
justement je vous rappelle que nous
étions de ce point de vue là dans une
situation d'emploi des jeunes notamment
des jeunes diplômés qui était tout à
fait favorable que par contre une veille
ont des problèmes structurels sur les
jeunes non diplômés et ce drame que
représente tous ceux sortant du système
scolaire aux alentours de bach - 2 sans
avoir aucune qualification ça c'est
autre chose générer que ça c'est du
structurel
ça n'est pas du conjoncturel et ça il
faut le rappeler
alors de grâce arrêtons et arrêtez de
tirer sur les ambulances
je crois très franchement que la france
traverse à traverser et traverse une
crise sans précédent et que globalement
cette crise a été à peu près rendue
supportable
c'est pas parfait mais c'est beaucoup
mieux
que ce que vous voyez dans nombre
d'autres pays qui est touché de la même
manière et qui vivent encore aujourd'hui
avec cette épée de damoclès dac vide
nous ne maîtrisons pas alors ensuite
mais que ça c'est l'historien qui
parlent que rapidement parce qu'on a
vraiment content nous ayons surmédiatisé
le coc vide par rapport à d'autres
pandémies du passé
là j'aurais tendance à être d'accord
la grippe espagnole qui fut autrement
plus dramatiques en 1919 et 1920 avait
été à l'époque totalement passée sous
silence
et il en a été de même de la grippe
asiatique de la fin des années 50
là nous avons vécu pour la première fois
une pandémie en temps réel et en temps
réel sur les médias et le problème c'est
que les politiques sont obligés aussi de
gérer avec les médias merci beaucoup ont
finalement d'avoir été parmi nous a dans
cette émission je rappelle que vous êtes
historien économiste et fondateur du
cercle cyclope olive et on continue avec
les questions cash question de quelle
vie prod normalement toute cette
création de monnaie par les banques
centrales cela devrait créer une
hyperinflation et les non pas tout de
suite dans un premier temps n'ont dans
un premier temps sacré plutôt de la
déflation c'est à dire que
[Musique]
vous avez toute cette toute cette
monnaie qui arrive en fait dans les
sociétés zombies si vous voulez qui donc
maintiennent une des surcapacités et ça
fait baisser les prix donc dans un
premier temps c'est plutôt
déflationniste
alors pourquoi parce que si vous voulez
le l'inflation c'est une composante de
deux choses 1 il faut créer de la
monnaie et puis ensuite il faut qu'elles
circulent ol ne circule pas aujourd'hui
elle circule pas dans l'économie réelle
la seule le seul endroit où elles
circulent c'est la bourse et là en effet
ben vous voyez le ce que ça donne c'est
à dire des indices qui n'arrête pas de
monter des valeurs qui sont complètement
déconnectés de la réalité et donc c'est
là que va l'argent c'est là qu'ils
circulent mais il circule pas dans
l'économie réelle donc vous ne pouvez
pas avoir d' inflation pour l'instant
mais il est évident que à force de créer
de la monnaie
avec derrière rien la dette uniquement
de la dette de créer de la monnaie comme
ça vous avez un risque qui est que a au
bout d'un moment les gens s'aperçoivent
que cette monnaie qui est créée ex
nihilo ne vaut rien et à ce moment là
vous obtenez ce que vous avez obtenus à
chaque fois qui a eu de la création
monétaire comme ça importante sous tendu
par ray 1
eh bien ça s'est toujours terminé de la
même façon par en effet une chute de la
monnaie qu'on appelle un justement de
l'hyperinflation une chute de la valeur
de la monnaie et et bientôt on se
promènera avec des brouettes remplies
d'argent pour aller s'acheter un timbre
merci olivier c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
rendez vous la semaine prochaine en
attendant pour voir ou revoir vos
précédents numéros rendez vous sur rt
france point tv olivier on se quitte
avec à votre roi de la fin j'ai peur que
les prévisions de croissance soit un
décompte qui ai commencé à 8 et qui
finira à 0